you can just follow your list or check
out the what's new or what's hot tabs or
you can dig a little deeper into the
Netflix archives to find some truly
outstanding under-the-radar films here's
a look at some of the best stuff to add
to your queue the next time you don't
know what to watch the duffer brothers
might allude to their spielberg Ian's
influences and aim and stranger things
but rim of the world director Mick
Gianna Bosch idli and cheerfully made an
eighty style kid adventure movie rim of
the world mixes elements of et The
Goonies and Red Dawn to create a
similarly fun sci-fi action movie where
teens save the day if you find yourself
alone riding in green fields with the
Sun on your face do not be troubled for
you're not Lisa and you're already dead
the simple irresistible premise for kids
arrive at summer camp just in time for
an invasion of the planet by wicked
aliens with the well populated rim of
the world Camp soon abandoned it's up to
this ragtag group of teens who don't
quite fit and elsewhere to come together
and thwart what amounts to the end of
the world they'll have to do it all
without adults computers or much of
anything except of course for bikes
heaven of horror says of this light
white diversion this is an absolute
treat for fans of sci-fi adventure
action and monster movies after bringing
so much attention and accolades to
Netflix via his unforgettable
performances sheriff popper on stranger
things it's no surprise that David
Harbor has free rein to do whatever he
wants at the streaming giant and what he
wants to do is a meta sci-fi and horror
laced mockumentary about his life a
collaboration with Arrested Development
writer John levenshtein the result is a
short special that's a bit hard to
define Frankenstein's monsters monster
Frankenstein is based around a mid 70s
made-for-tv production of the two-man
theatrical version of Frankenstein the
twist is that Harbor plays his own
father also an actor named David Harbor
as the two generations play both dr.
Frankenstein and his monstrous creation
at the same time to round out this
tribute from the younger Harbor to the
fictional older Harbor our clips of the
actor from other vintage fictional
productions like The Crying detective
and the
trunk the whole thing winds up both a
love letter to the craft of acting and
an affectionate send-up of the entire
notion of playing pretend for a living
this 2017 indie horror movie by writer
director Trey Edward Schultz feels like
an old-fashioned kind of horror movie
sure it trades in spooky monsters and
frightening imagery but it's more about
conjuring up what's already inside the
viewer the unspeakable dread of things
yet to come it comes at night is set
deep in a remote woodland area not long
after an epidemic has wiped out most of
human life on earth it's where the small
family of Paul Sara and young Travis try
to survive on what little supplies
they've got and hope that they don't get
infected with the plague but then danger
comes looking for them in the form of a
roving family man named will who is
maybe not the innocent guy he claims to
be I listen I don't even have to shoot
you you know I could just leave you out
here you want his water still Sara
invites will and his family into their
homestead on the theory of strength in
numbers but that only seems to invite
more danger most of it impossibly
horrific lurking out there in the forest
the London Evening Standard Charlotte
O'Sullivan said of the film it made me
so tense I could hardly breathe let
alone think Vietnam is home to a quickly
developing movie culture and industry
and the action thriller fury teams up
two of its stars director LaVon ket and
actress Veronica best known to Western
audiences as Gunnar Paige Tico in star
wars the last Jedi in fury in portrays a
former criminal overlord who now works
as the muscle for a loan shark in the
city of Caen foe shaking down
delinquents with a shattering of a
kneecap or two that violence comes home
to roost when her daughter my is
kidnapped and seemingly sold to black
market organ dealers hmm propelled by
equal parts rage guilt and love takes to
the seedy sides of Ho Chi Minh City to
get her daughter back in one piece
fury is a tight often sparse ride which
includes plenty of novel set pieces
beautiful cinematography and an intense
motorbike chase sometimes the scariest
parts of a scary movie don't come from
monsters or gore but from menace and
red that's what propels the precisely
paced earthquake bird based on the novel
of the same name by Susannah Jones
Alicia vikander of ex machina returns to
the kind of moody unsettling cinema that
made her famous portraying Lucy a
Swedish expatriate who has settled into
a life in 1989 Tokyo that is repetitive
bland and mundane it's by design as
she's looking to flee from and forget
past traumas she works as a translator
living alone while maintaining some
low-key friendships and playing cello in
a string quartet one day Lucy meets
teiji a noodle shop worker and aspiring
photographer she enchants him and lets
him make portraits of her I've never had
my picture taken before properly then I
am the first but just when it seems like
her icy veneer is starting to thaw
Lucy's life is interrupted by a brash
American named Lily who goes missing and
is presumed dead is the mysterious Lucy
responsible either via conscious act or
her status as a tragedy magnet or is she
merely an unreliable narrator
Gabriel silver of the Detroit Metro
Times said earthquake bird is an
enjoyable neo-noir film with enough
twists and turns to leave you thinking
long after the ending yes it's a
thriller set at a lake deep in the woods
and a young person dies very early on in
the movie apart from that setup and the
notion that an unrepentant killer could
strike at any time every time I die is
as far away as can be from your typical
horror the film follows the forlorn sam
who is still recovering from the
childhood tragedy of losing a sister to
drowning now a paramedic he keeps his
mind off his troubles with an ongoing
affair with a married woman
that is until he's killed at the hands
of her husband returning soldier Tyler
that's when every time I die takes a
turn Drew's unsettled consciousness
floats into the bodies of his friends
attempting to warn them that they could
be the next to die the film's tightly
packed 98 minute running time and
minuscule budgets serve it well as it
winds up a rarity in cinema a pensive
thriller Andrew Stover a film inquiry
said of every time I die
it's a captivating little tale about
self-image with a mystical and poignant
touch
Don is just a regular guy a lawyer whose
life has taken a few bad turns because
of his own bad decisions seeking a fresh
start before his wife Lyz gives birth to
their first child
he buys a decrepit old house way out in
suburban Chicago he moves in first so
that he can pour himself into renovating
this old spooky Manor somehow Don
doesn't go screaming back into the city
when he discovers that the house bleeds
and excretes a strange white fluid out
of its pipes or when he keeps
discovering human and animal corpses and
freaky ghostly monsters as if all that
isn't enough he's got to contend with a
flirty neighbor who may know more about
the source of the houses Horrors than
she's letting on girl on the third floor
marks the screenwriting and direct oral
debut of veteran horror producer Travis
Stevens the haunted house movie is a
well traveled genre but Stevens tweaks
the formula enough to leave audiences
guessing entertained and unsettled based
on the originality and success of The
Matrix
Hollywood has frequently given the
Wachowski x' a blank check to make
whatever visually dazzling unabashedly
earnest and totally bonkers sci-fi movie
they felt like making one of those
movies is Jupiter ascending which stars
Mila Kunis as Jupiter Jones a Russian
American house cleaner and amateur
astronomer through a string of events
that involve selling her eggs to pay for
a telescope she finds out she's some
kind of Space Princess the Abra sax clan
a prominent galactic family wants her
dead or maybe just control of her
birthright fortunately she's got the
steadfast protection from Cain wise
played by Channing Tatum a half human
half wolf super soldier Jupiter
ascending is a bit of an overstuffed
sci-fi extravaganza and it has
everything from jetpacks to giant
spaceships to hand-to-hand combat to
Sean Bean playing a rogue bee man
Stephanie cook of rogues portal manages
to sum up the film's many joys in one
pithy remark ever wondered what
cinderella The Godfather and Teen Wolf
would look like if they were one movie
no well too bad because Jupiter
ascending exists it's not pretty easy
and stripped markup a court martialed
skyjacker stubbornness with my question
do you want your wings back or not he
had wings why our period horror film so
much scarier than one set in the modern
day is it because the relative ignorance
and brutality of the past adds an extra
element of terror or are images of
Victorian era Londoners in bleak clothes
living bleak lives inherently unsettling
that could be the answer
although blood hungry monsters freaky
islands and blood Colts are scary too
fortunately apostle showcases all that
and much more said in 1905 apostle
follows a man named Thomas who leaves
London for an island paradise off the
coast of Wales
it's run by a cult and Thomas must
retrieve his sister taken to the island
by the group and held for ransom he
poses as a new adherent to gain favor
with the cult members and their leader
prophet Malcolm all while aiming to get
his sister back however things get
awfully sticky for Thomas when he
realizes that the Colts teachings aren't
exactly crazy those jars of blood
everyone carries around to collect their
blood sacrifice to the island the island
needs that blood
imagine if Little Shop of Horrors
matched up with the Wickerman and you've
got apostle just stood me her wisdom
trusted me that I may enrich you our
minds according to the thoughtful sci-fi
movie I owe humanity is doomed to never
change its ways and in the
not-too-distant future earth becomes
uninhabitable
fortunately scientists have found a new
home for mankind on Io one of Jupiter's
many moons a scientist named Sam is
among the handful of humans who haven't
made the migration to IO just yet
staying behind to test the water and air
for signs of decreasing toxicity as well
as to raise bees that she hopes could
someday pollinate and help save the
planets vegetation time is running out
and certain catastrophic events lead Sam
to head with another survivor Micah to a
shuttle that will take them into space
io is full of philosophical and mental
tension as these to bear witness to what
could be Earth's final extinct ofwomen
but also
newfound hope for the future Lee Monson
of birth movies death says if you're
looking for science fiction that makes
manifest the anxieties of a dying world
our dying world then IO is a good place
to start we weren't ready for this no
matter what warning we got from people
like your father what if John wick were
more like an 80s movie or violent more
nihilistic more violent soaked and with
more absolutely unnecessary nudity all
with a gleeful undercurrent of shock
humor permeating the whole thing that's
polar the bonkers messy story of one
man's quest to relax and secure his
pension mass Mickelson the Danish actor
best known for his starring role on the
stylish TV version of Hannibal stars as
Duncan Vizsla aka the black kaiser
duncan is a highly effective assassin
forced by his oddly corporate bosses to
retire at age 50 and enjoy his golden
years of course his company plans to
kill him to avoid paying his payout from
a lovely cabin in Montana Duncan has to
fight off some violent attacks while
also dealing with PTSD and forging a
friendship with a neighbor with demons
of her own know they pay well for this
Vivien I'm still going to give you a
chance to walk out of your life all time
sake check out one of our newest videos
right here Plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you